next uh larry elder
of course running for governor of
california
was walking through los angeles
yesterday
and here's something that if you follow
conservative media you've probably
already seen this
if you don't follow it
then you haven't seen this but you
certainly would well you're about to
we'll play the clip what you're about to
see here
just imagine
any
non-white democrat
experiencing exactly what we're gonna
see with larry elder
and it would be non-stop news across the
country headlines for two weeks easily
here it is
hey
might have been hard to tell what was
going on there if you weren't watching
the video uh that was uh a leftist woman
in a gorilla mask
running up and throwing an egg at larry
elder and she missed you know frankly
she was thrown like a girl and she did
miss
but then his security goes up and she's
getting in the securities
guy's face say do something
prop saying that he that she would uh i
think her words were f him up
this little tiny scrawny that's that's
always frustrating when you see these
videos
that these
antifa wusses all get away with that
um because the security guy no i assume
that was security he he knows that if he
responds at all even though at that
point i mean he's being physically
assaulted now by this woman if he
responds at all physically then he's
going to be the one who ends up in jail
this is california after all
now as i said there's there's
no question at all that if this happened
to a black democrat or any non-white
democrat
uh this would be
headline news two two weeks i mean it
would be like the only thing you heard
about
um and there's no doubt about that
now a lot of people on the right are
pointing that out and putting it out for
good reason
and you're also hearing that this is
this is racist this is racism towards
larry elder
uh
i mean i'm i'm fine with that accusation
or or that uh
interpretation of the events because if
it was reversed that's what everybody
would be saying so that's fair
enough i will say in reality i i don't
think it actually is
racism exactly
uh i think there was a racist message
she was trying to send i mean why else
would she be
dressed like
that
but
does she hate larry elder because
he's black
probably not
i mean if he was the exact same guy
exact same skin color
and he was singing the tune that she
that she prefers
uh you know and he had the blm t-shirt
and he was saying tran black trans lives
matter or something and he's wearing a
t-shirt that said that then then she
wouldn't have done that
i think
what it is more so than racism this is
just that people on that side
especially the radicals antifa and
everything
they just don't recognize the humanity
of anybody who disagrees with them
so if you disagree with them if you have
a
world view that differs from their own
then all bets are off
they could be racist towards you they
could be sexist towards you they could
do anything and kill you i mean they can
do whatever they want
because you're not a person anymore
no matter what your race is
uh and that applies regardless of race
so that that's what this is actually
that doesn't make it better
it's just as bad
but that's what's actually happening
here
it's not it's not so much
oh we hate larry elder because he's a
black man it's
he disagrees with us so he's a piece of
garbage and worthless and so we can
treat him however we want and this is
how we're going to treat him
if his if his race contributes at all to
the treatment um
and it might
it's because people on the left feel
that
if you're black then they then they own
you
you you you owe something to them
and if you disagree with them especially
if you're running for governor of
california as a republican how dare you
then
not only do they hate you for your
worldview
but also on top of it they consider you
a traitor to them
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content